sort of amazing news to reports tonight
not really a Fox News Alert but very
close Adam kinzinger leaves Congress and
then someone hires him someone literally
hired Adam kinzinger for a job you may
not believe it but Trace Gallagher of
Fox News can confirm it who's watching
another Channel tonight when he learned
Trish Scott what did you see well after
seeing its ratings plummet over the past
two years Tucker CNN has informed the
world that it will no longer be a far
left media organization and will instead
go back to being an unbiased news source
as if there was evidence that CNN was
ever an unbiased news source but to
prove that things are changing CNN has
now hired former GOP congressman Adam
kinzinger as not just a political
analyst mind you but the Network's
senior political analyst which is no
surprise to this show which just days
ago predicted this watch in just weeks
Adam Kinser will be another CNN
contributor no one will ever see him
again
but we will never forget him
Bingo and it appears to be a good fit
considering the only one who hates
former president Trump more than CNN is
Adam kinzinger remember it was kinzinger
who voted to impeach Trump kinzinger who
was a member of the January 6 committee
said if Trump was not charged with
inciting an Insurrection the future of
the country is doomed and kinzinger who
called Trump's GOP quote kind of creepy
got to be looking forward to the promos
right kinzinger and CNN the dynamic
unbiased Duo providing some senior
political analysis Trish Gallagher the
best great to see you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight